this is a production of Cornell
University this is really a privilege to
be back at Cornell University in this
very same room to have memories of very
distinguished speakers and learning from
them so I'm I'm thrilled to be here is
this loud enough in my is an in a good
position okay so I'll just go ahead and
get started and try to attempt to leave
as much time as possible for discussion
so let's see okay we may have to stand
here okay it is working okay so first of
all I like to start with a list of all
the private sector funding I've received
to talk about genetic engineering and
and CRISPR and that is the list right
there so this is important because you
know in fact I've never done CRISPR so
never engineered a plant so I'm an
outsider to this field and I think that
gives me a certain degree of perspective
which might be helpful having received
funds to do genetic engineering it's not
a it's not a problem in fact that's how
you become experts but I can say
honestly that I don't have any conflicts
of interest in this area and I and it
because it's so controversial I think
it's important to make sure that's clear
so my motivations I've learned that it's
it's probably good to be explicit about
my vote of motivations and I believe
that the wise use of CRISPR new
technologies and genetic engineering
contributes to the comment or can
contribute to the common good through
increased food security and more
sustainable food systems that's my
motivation for coming to Cornell well
through the Alliance for science most of
all in this case but for this as well so
this is the outline I'm in it looks like
a lot but we'll get through it because
some of these topics or rather short
CRISPR genetic engineering and disease
distance and you can you can read it for
yourselves starting with crisper I want
to just say a few things about it first
of all plant transformation has been
accomplished largely by two technologies
that have been very useful one is to use
Agra bacteria in the natural genetic
engineer to to basically transform
plants and the second was to use the
gene gun particle bombardment a lot of
you were very familiar with these these
and am I still speaking loud enough if I
talk like this okay so so those have
been useful technologies in introducing
genetic constructs of interest in random
locations in the genome but nevertheless
useful CRISPR I think first of all let
me explain it briefly and then and then
distinguish it in from plant
transformation there are two elements to
the CRISPR nanomachine I guess we could
think of it as that I've already called
that the orange whoops okay all right so
the orange bubbly thing is the caz nine
site-specific nucleus and the the the
gray to green structure there is the
single guide RNA and working together
the RNA guide RNA leads the cast nine to
a particular site based on Watson based
Watson Crick base pairing and it Cleaves
at a particular location on that in that
double stranded DNA and so that's what
the that's what the Kurtz work as nine
single guide RNA does but it's what
happens after that results in gene
editing and and so now we've got a
double-stranded break and so the cell is
going to repair that you know as quickly
as possible sometimes often introducing
any an insertion or deletion of a small
number of nucleotides you know refer to
why that's important in just a few
minutes if you include into the same
cell a template that has homology to
both sides of this
cut but has this blue gene that's new
and you can introduce an additional
genetic construct into into the
breakpoint so if we were to imagine that
that blue gene that we've introduced has
some value in terms of conferring
disease resistance then and that would
be easy to imagine that that could
contribute to disease control this one
here though I want to comment on because
we're introducing in Dells into a gene
that you know and so we're causing
disruption to the the gene but why would
that be important because if you if you
target a susceptibility gene with a
within introduce an in Dell there then
if you've done that across all homeo
alleles for that plan this is weed in
this case which is a hexaploid then
you've created a resistant plant okay
and this is one of the ways that
actually this is being used so we've got
two ways general ways that could
introduce disease resistance there are
multiple ways that the the CRISPR the
the Cassadine single-eyed RNA can be
introduced into a eukaryotic cell but
the one that without going into those in
detail or we've leave more time for
discussion but the one that caught my
attention the most is represented here
and so this is actually where a there's
no introduction of DNA into the plant
it's just the combination of the Kaz 9
represented as purple the Kaz 9 enzyme
and the single guide RNA and those are
joined together in a ribonucleic alejo
protein which can be transfected into
protoplasts or introduced by the gene
gun and and again that's been described
as DNA free gene editing so I think it's
just an interesting concept but there
are other ways that the cast 9 and the
single guide are and it can be
introduced another thing I think is
notable about the CRISPR gene editing is
people have successfully multiplexed
with multiple single guide RNAs so we
can actually target several genes at one
time
in the same cell and so what are some of
the important features of Chris Burke as
nine gene-editing
first of all most important I think is
the precision this introduced introduces
very targeted and specific breaks that
occur at specific locations or
insertions that have occurred it's
defined locations and that distinguishes
it from the the previous forms of plant
genetic engineering it introduces
flexibility because not only are we
introducing a particular gene but we can
delete a gene we can delete a fragment
we can use targeted mutations or create
targeted mutations so there's there's
there's more that you can accomplish
then than previously generally reported
by researchers is a predictable type of
technology this is what I read and again
I see researchers were commonly referred
to it as democratizing genetic
engineering because it's rather simply
that it's rather simple to apply I that
has been subject to discussion I've
heard a researcher once say well once
they recently actually said well you
actually have to optimize CRISPR for
every given plant species so maybe maybe
it's really no different in this respect
then plant transformation but enough
people have said it that I I think it's
worth at least mentioning the one
wrinkle that I think is worth talking
about and hopefully we'll have time for
others as you wish but is this this
concept of off-target
mutations and so here we have the guide
RNA represented in DNA strand that is
that is the RNA that will guide the
CRISPR to a particular target ok so
there's it's going to it's going to
match this sequence completely but there
are other parts in this genome this is
rice right this is there are other other
locations in this genome where there's
not quite a perfect match but there is
the possibility of annealing of the
single guide RNA resulting in a you know
break a cut in a target that is not
actually the target for the for the RNA
and so these are called off-target
mutations okay and and you read at least
the popular literature there's they're
raised as concerns I don't think they
they are published this in a blog and
had a peer-reviewed but but these are
the reasons first of all implants what I
see in the literature is the reported
off-target rates are quite low and and
there's additional papers that I can
cite now and add to that a number of
thirteen citations so it seems pretty
uncommon implants there are strategies
for reducing off-target mutations and
these continue to be published
off target mutations number three can be
monitored you can find out if they're
there right through the whole genome
sequencing for in sexually reproducing
crops undesired mutations can be
segregated out and most of all it I
think it's it makes a lot of sense in a
clinical situation for human disease
control and therapeutics to to avoid off
target mutations if we possibly can but
with plants I I'm not sure I see the
risk because in breeding of all sorts
there is a lot of off target changes
beyond the particular genetic change
that we're interested in and that never
has raised a concern I think if there
are off target mutations infrequent
though they might be that are
detrimental to the plant we select those
out and that's and then that's it now I
do want to bring attention to this paper
here which has just published a few
weeks ago actually not published it's in
a preprint server so it's it's not been
published in a journal but but they
documented seemingly you know well done
way to my eye of translocation and and
chromosome duplication proportions of a
chromosome being duplicated they
documented both of those as a result of
CRISPR cast nine editing in a rabid
abscess so I still think the same
response applies it is that a problem to
implants particularly good since we can
we select and you test the progeny but I
think it's an area that's worth paying
attention to and certainly we're
searching so so we'll see where this
leads
okay genetic engineering and disease
resistance will flash through it just a
few slides first of all I wished a paper
in the journal sustainability on genetic
engineering from my perspective as a
plant pathologist and went through and
actually described the different
strategies maybe I'll show that this is
open access by the way if you're
interested okay so these top what I
think ten strategies were described in
the paper and cited for examples and
then promptly within a few months of
publication there were a couple more
strategies that were published the point
is that there are there is quite and
within each of these strategies you have
a pretty wide landscape of possibilities
for engineering disease resistance so
and and and so we've got we've got a
dozen at least right strategies for
engineering resistance and I want you to
be impressed by the possibilities that's
not to say there aren't concerns but but
there's a lot we can do we know we can
do already maybe not all of it would be
workable in the field but some of them
would so my conclusion from the
literature and talking to experts is
gene-editing it seems to be capable of
writing all the transgenic and all the
SIS genic types of resistance that have
been published as a result of genetic
engineering and it can also provide
targeting mutations large deletions and
allele substitutions which was not to my
knowledge possible before ok genetics
and crop pesticides so this goes this is
going to draw on my experiences as a
applied young plant a plant pathologist
and dr. Laura beers program first of all
I'll talk a maybe i should point out
that among the three categories of
pesticides
there's herbicides which is the largest
category of use of herbicides these are
all day
but still we're in the ballpark here
insecticides and my decides represent
the second category and fungicides and
other chemicals for Disease Control are
represented in the third category so
let's take the first one and that is
herbicide tolerant crops so or
herbicides
how could CRISPR play a role in reducing
herbicides is the question and one way
might be to engineer plants for
herbicide tolerance okay that's one
possibility
so if we look at a recent review paper
on the use of CRISPR research or
publication or Reserve results in in
using CRISPR yield was the principal
focus biofortification was was number
two and number three is herbicide
tolerance basically so pretty high on
the list and I know if the large-scale
manufacturers are using this in their
research programs to create plants that
are resistant to herbicides so let's
look at the experience with Roundup
Ready crops glyphosate tolerant crops
and that's that picture tells it all
these plants have been engineered to
resist an herbicide that would normally
kill all plants right it's been very
useful technology very useful to the
farmer you just have to ask a farmer is
is you know why do you use this
technology and you'll hear and you know
so that's that's the one side of the
equation the other side is this and so
here we have glyphosate resistant mares
tail it's one of the species that's
resistant to glyphosate in many parts of
the United States so that's I think that
I think it's fair even though the
technology's been useful to farmers it's
fair to refer to this kind of pesticide
treadmill where does it end right so so
we can talk more about glyphosate but my
point is that I don't think CRISPR
represents a near-term solution to the
challenge of reducing herbicide use
well actually let me let me add to that
because a couple of other possibilities
for the use of CRISPR to reduce
herbicide use is represented here and
that is one jeans jeans for allelopathy
can be introduced into another species
of a crop and so now the roots of the
plant become a source of the stalks into
two weeds that's being done with solutes
or goli own from from sorghum in a
research capacity it's not anything I
see as near-term commercial
what about Fitness suppressing gene
drives engineering the weed to to spread
a gene drive within its population that
is Fitness suppressive it's a great
concept it's being done in a research
capacity we're nowhere near commercial
use of that you know there's a lot of
issues to consider so bottom line is I
don't see CRISPR as providing a solution
to the review with respect to the
reduction of herbicide use in contrast
with respect to insecticides Maite size
and disease control chemicals my opinion
from where I stand is this is
low-hanging fruit
this is low-hanging fruit from again
think back to where - all the
possibilities that I described before
knowing that sure there'll be challenges
but this this is a very underutilized
technology in my mind alright so this is
a slide from Orange County New York I've
worked with Jim more beer for five years
on onions had a great experience and
this this a toasty crispy onion plot is
was is from natural inoculum all we ask
the grower to do was turn off the
sprayer and that's the kind of disease
pressure that was out there so clearly
they're gonna have a good reason to use
fungicides I we have that level of
susceptibility in the commercial ground
so I wanted to start with that sort of
fundamental notion that you know there
there there could be it - may a pretty
big demand for it that's hard to dispute
so the principle that this represents is
shown in the title slide and
complete resistance can displace the
need for pesticide no question about it
this is this is not genetically
engineered this is just these are
different turf grass varieties that's
got a very destructive root disease that
one has got the same soil so clearly
it's resistant and I'm telling you
against that disease if you want to
control with fungicide you're gonna be
spraying a lot so so you know obviously
this would be a much better choice this
this case does involve genetic
engineering it's a sis genic approach to
controlling late blight and all these
plants are engineered with that cysteine
and here is the plant that's not and so
again complete resistance can displace
the need for pesticides that's that is
something that is fundamentally really
well known among applied plant
pathologists there's another case from
genetic engineering this is insecticide
use in corn has gone down dramatically
since the introduction of BT traits for
insect control and it's that that is I
think entirely attributable to that and
in other parts of the world we've seen
similar reductions in insecticide use
with BT crops BT brinjal or eggplant in
Bangladesh has been widely adopted by
farmers because they typically I've read
this in multiple places scholarly
sources typically they were would be
spraying seventy to eighty times a
growing season or more to control the
borer and now they're down to very low
numbers that's not to say there aren't
issues and concerns but but the the
point is that that there can be
reductions in pesticide use from genetic
engineering and we're not no-one
surprised by that it works in the field
another example I like this example from
Florida this is bacterial spot of tomato
here we have the same variety with a
single gene from for for pathogen
recognition a single receptor
that comes from front pepper right from
pepper and they as I understand it the
only reason this hasn't yet been
commercialized is because there they
don't know how to handle the public
relations challenge of a GMO but it but
it it's anyway it's published it it
looks good seems to work and this is
what they're doing presently and what
what our growers doing Kentucky I don't
know if you have much bacterial spot
here in this climate but and they're
spraying copper and copper is not good
for the environment it's not good for
the workers so I think my opinion this
is actually more sustainable so here's a
paper by go fry going back to 1975 but
still really kind of a classic paper
what he showed what he did was he he
plotted the apparent infection rates
against fungicide dose for two varieties
a more susceptible variety russet rural
I think was called in some Sebago here
and so this this differential there's a
slight interaction so the differentials
different along different parts but this
differential shows the the Aquila Chiva
Beluga side as a result of this partial
resistance so complete resistance is a
no-brainer when we have complete
resistance we we we can reduce
pesticides to zero maybe sometimes and
then on the circumstances here but even
partial resistance can reduce the need
for fungicide and that's what that paper
shows so it is it is well established
that genetic engineering can produce
disease resistant plants and genetic
solutions can displace pesticides for
control of diseases and insects these
these are I think well established so
if if genetics are underutilized then
how do we do it sustainably next and so
I think there are two fundamental ways
that we you can use genetics sustainably
and and when I say sustainable I mean
for the indefinite future how do we how
do we do it in for the indefinite future
not that I have all the answers but I'm
going to offer what I think about this
first of all and it all depends on
diversity it all depends on diversity so
one way to use genetic resources is to
not depend just on genetic resources so
make sure to deploy a diversity and
control tactics and we have a name for
that it's called integrated pest
management so crop rotation has a role
in the deployment of genetics
sustainably planting dates that might
influence disease pressure have a role
in deploying genetics is sustainable and
secondly diversity and gened appointment
okay diversity ingenuity gene deployment
so that by that I mean multiple things
first of all let's go back to this list
from my paper and sustainability two
years ago remember there are lots of
strategies that can lead to the
production of plants that are resistant
to disease and remember with each of
these strategies there I don't know what
the limit would be to the particular
applications that by that microbiologist
might conceive so I really see the
potential for a lot of diversity in in
the in the the genetic mechanisms that
we use so so what I mean by diversity
and gene deployment is is the list I'm
about to show first of all use diverse
mechanisms right use diverse mechanisms
the Beatty trait has been used heavily
for multiple reasons
in reality the best way to protect the
Beatty trade is to have another genetic
trait that is as a distinct mechanism
from the from Beatty and the targets the
same pest so diverse mechanisms you know
it's one way to slow pathogen adaptation
separate from that multiple why not
target multiple targets again this is
I'm assuming we're in a world where
genetic where GMOs are not considered
necessarily intrinsically harmful right
so a world where society is willing to
utilize technology systems and we're not
there but I'm going to talk about it
from the standpoint of biology and then
we'll we'll go forward as the public
wishes but multiple targets so I saw an
interesting paper on reductions of that
really actually pretty surprising
reductions in alpha toxin accumulation
and they targeted three points on the
particular gene of interest so why not
do that against other pests target
multiple sites make it basically harder
for the pathogen to adapt gene
pyramiding this is a concept that is not
certainly novel to genetic engineering
or CRISPR but but it certainly would be
easier to implement through the use of a
CRISPR engineered construct and at least
for for annuals and biennials why not
rotate again assuming that the public is
willing to have us use diverse genetic
techniques but you know like in corn for
example may this I don't know if this is
naive but it seems to me that you could
build in actually this goes back to the
multi lines work that I've read a bit
red belt when I was a graduate student
and thereafter if you why not you know
have every five years you rotate to a
different set of genes
resistance against X disease and you
just build that into your your program
and it's worth pointing out that high
throughput gene discovery and cloning
techniques just expand the pus about the
landscape even more allowing us to
implement this principle of diversity
and gene department so I think all of
these are possible through conventional
breeding but they're probably
facilitated through genetic engineering
including through and especially through
CRISPR so I I do believe from my
perspective the gene editing is likely
to permit more rapid breeding responses
to evolving pathogen populations so yeah
but we've got a we've always got to
think not I am excited about the
potential for with the wise use of
CRISPR I'm you know I mean it's pretty
hard to hide that but our job is as
scientists is to be willing to look at
the full picture right and that's part
of what will happen in the discussion
but but he and so here's one example I
mean as a biologist this this one
certainly catches my attention so so for
at least for a period of time there was
only one Bt toxin event using cotton
worldwide so I mean it's again it's
pretty easy to imagine that that kind of
widespread use of a single gene
construct could represent a risk right
how do we know
well I credit Roy Moore for those who
you remember him he he taught a
wonderful fight I think was a 500 level
course that was grueling with the
laboratories but but boy did I learn a
lot and so southern corn the leaf blade
is a disease that still exists but but
in 1970 what happened was very severe
epidemic developed in the United States
due to the presence of so there's the
epidemic and you know in Kentucky and
that is not fall coloration because you
can see this trees are green that is an
epidemic that happened why throughout
the United much of the corn growing area
and where she had the infection
progressed into the grain itself which
was unusual and it turned out that the
that a mitochondrial gene there it is
identified by mitochondrial gene that
conferred cytoplasmic male sterility
actually also had a pleiotropic effect
in conferring hyper susceptibility to an
unknown strain of southern corn leaf
blight so this genetic and this is all
natural this is all the result of
conventional breeding so we're not
picking on genetic engineering or
conventional breeding so this this
natural genetic trait was what
predisposed unknown advanced was
predisposed to crop to this epidemic so
we know that the widespread use of a
particular genetic construct
could lead to an unexpected outcomes we
have to recognize that as biologists but
but overall my opinion is that the
sustainable use of genetic research
resources for disease control actually
puts more would would depend on greater
reliance on genetic knowledge and
innovation not what not less not less
knowledge and not less application but
greater reliance as you as you've seen
ok social considerations we're not going
to go into the deeply but I think it's
important to give voice to the social
dimension of these technologies and you
know everyone that social scientists ask
is who decides where to use the
technology in wet and I don't think
there is an easy answer to that but it's
a good thing to wonder as
who decides who benefits before we use
it who might be the beneficiary at what
rate is it used you know again I don't
think I know the answers who might be
disadvantaged and does genetic
engineering promote food access and
those are the things that interested me
most the things that can contribute to
sustainability in a social sense or an
environmental sense so that's that's why
I I think it's important to think beyond
and talk beyond just the glyphosate
roundup ready trait that's the most
common one of the other dimensions that
I think is important to recognize as as
biologists is the fact that trans gene
flow recognizing trans genes or genes
from outside the breeding pool and the
flow of trans genes could represent a
risk right to environments or the
environment or or cultural risks and so
I don't have the easy answer for this
one either so this is these are
campesino farmers in nicaragua and they
they produce their own ancient varieties
and so you know if we get trans gene
flow with Roundup Ready trade into their
variety even if it occurs at low
percentage and even if it has no
economic impact whatsoever they don't
want it in their corn so I think we've
got to recognize that as an issue that
applies to trans jeans
I don't think the same applies if we
engineered our corn with a cysteine
which is from the breeding pool of corn
I don't think the same applies if we
take create a deletion or an endo cause
in targeting mutations because all of
those things can happen naturally in the
Oh in the gene pool of the crop but
within in the case of trans jeans I
think this represents an issue social
risk
but not all applications of oh yeah
actually yeah there is another point and
so when some of my good friends are more
concerned about the impact of genetic
engineering on on small holders there he
is saving a seed could he save the seed
if it you know was a genetically
engineered crop and you know here in the
United States no at least not until you
know the label is off the product is off
patent so again it's that sort of a
social consideration not a biological
one but it's important nevertheless not
all applications of genetic engineering
are harmful to small holders some are
beneficial and here's just a few
examples done with small holders in mind
this work the furka project is is to
create disease resistance against
cassava diseases they I'm sure they do
others in this project but that was
that's the one that got my attention and
they are categorically they
categorically must distribute those
genetic traits once they're publicly
released they must distribute those
freely and to allow them to be shared so
this is these are poisonings incidents
of acute poisonings in among cotton
growers in India and BT of course is the
engineered plant and non bt is non
engineered and the the the incidence of
no poisonings was high at much higher
for those who had he had BT crop they
weren't spraying as many insecticides
makes sense right and they you see that
all the way up through to all these
different categories the incidence of
multiple poisonings was lower where they
use BT because they weren't dependent on
insecticides I've seen the same kind of
data from China so again I it's an
example of how not all examples of
genetic engineering are harmful to small
holders they may be beneficial here
one that again caught my attention this
was work again with cotton by its are
cotton bt cotton in colombia and it
reports that the women farmers actually
preferred the bt cotton because it saved
them time and it allowed them to have
less cost and spread hiring somebody to
spray their cotton so some reflections
we're gonna end up with 20th time which
is good so um I took that picture I did
not get over sprayed so I had it all
planned out very well but that's from
Orange County New York and so if we want
to reduce pesticides against diseases in
insects we must give farmers
alternatives I don't know of any other
way as an applied plant pathologist here
is a producer smallholder producer in
nicaragua and he's spraying chemicals
and he was actually spraying Cortile no
Jim no protection and you know I'd like
to see him to have an option here and
he's probably going to keep spraying
until he has an option and most of the
time options mean some sort of genetic
solution genetic engineering
conventional breeding something in this
I took all these pictures this was in
Nicaragua as well and that little girl
is about ten meters from that rice field
which gets treated by airplane that's
not good that is a bad situation
and so I I would like to see options if
we want this grower to stop using
pesticides from the air we have to give
him or her alternatives we know I've
spent still hard to believe 35 years
working with pesticides for Disease
Control starting in 1983 with you Morgan
when wonderful learning experience I've
been working that long with these and
I've you know i think i think most apply
plant pathologists would agree that
playing resistance is the principle
pathway to reducing pesticide use again
I'm not saying it necessarily has to be
crisper
but we need genetic solutions and we're
not we're not getting enough of them at
this point my perception is that CRISPR
based gene editing is it opens doors to
engineering disease resistance and
sometimes with advantages compared to
transformation or conventional breeding
and maybe it gives us target crops that
are heavily dependent on we saw some
slides so yeah we've discussed so that's
great way yeah that's a really good
question I you know I I think that's one
of those things I'm probably as in tree
I am as interested in your what you
think about it is whatever I think how
do we describe these technologies I so I
may change my mind on the plane home
after the discussion but I tend to so I
do a lot of outreach on this topic with
the public and I usually ask for about
an hour and a half and in that period of
time I
I have the leisure to be able to talk
using some pretty useful graphics you
know what what is genetic engineering
what is crisper and how is it used and
and you know there can be some overlap
in the outcomes right you know but but
but they are distinct I I have tend to
describe it all as genetic engineering
to the public and as long as people
understand and get comfortable with what
you know how genetic engineering is like
copying and pasting sentences copied
from this file paste of that file right
the sentence is the gene and now we've
just placed it into another file and
everybody knows how to do that and
they're like oh okay it's not that
mysterious if they understand that it
almost it almost doesn't matter which
language whether I call it genetic
engineering or precision breeding or
something the problem is that I have an
hour and a half and with many times you
have ten seconds so I want to present it
transparently it seems as a scientist to
be under the large umbrella of genetic
engineering but that might scare people
and yeah it's it's a dilemma because I
want I want to convey is you know the
accuracy of the phrase yes perfect yes
yes well stated yeah I think it does if
we're if we if we use words that avoid
you know what they what people might
think we're really talking about then we
we do run the risk of losing trust and
and I will tell you trust is everything
in this work I can't tell you how
important is it there's a yeah I can
there's a way to do it this is a this is
a saying that I learned somewhere people
don't care how much you know until they
know how much you care so so yeah
putting it you raise a good point and
putting it in those terms I think
anything that diminishes the trust
people have in us as public servants
which we all are you know
all trying to get a job and you know be
happy in our lives but we are working in
a public institution and I think that
Trust is we've got to do everything we
can to protect it but these are great
comments and be interesting hear from
you yeah industry have so much of our
some of the issue is is this going to be
affordable to use for its purpose what
I've seen from the media is that there's
additional yeah well I don't anticipate
it being more expensive than current you
know practices of genetic engineering I
think we
have to wait and see I haven't seen you
know I'm seeing much that indicates you
know the long-term cost to farmers and
and so on one of the things though it
definitely represents an opportunity and
corporations can't price their products
out of the market you know obviously I
went to it's called CRISPR con the
CRISPR conference Berkeley I know maybe
you're familiar with it yeah it's it was
a great conference and because it had
people from all walks of life
you know attending and and they did
these little surveys that you could
respond to on your phone and and so what
you know I think people responded we had
a pretty good survey results and when
they asked the question what sector D
represent a what area she represented
half where agriculture what and and so
that means you know all the applications
in the therapeutic world and you know
and other applications were the other
half in other words the big one by far
was agricultural uses so it must have a
lot of potential to make money for so
many people to be there from the
agricultural world
you know these were company
representatives and sure maybe
large-scale farmers but not not small
farmers but um so I yeah there's I I
worry a little bit that it's going to be
used principally for herbicide tolerance
and again I I think that's I respect the
benefit is brought to the growers who
use it I totally do and it's not it's
not the kind of application that excites
me because of all the things that we
could be doing so maybe maybe the cost
issues we'll learn more as we go through
I don't know what there will be them
yeah plants with approaches to avoiding
such as like polar polyculture
you know
no systematic research in that area yeah
and so you know I made the point that
diversifying disease control tactics is
is going to be important to reducing the
pressure and the selection pressure on
the pests and and that's that's true
whether we're dealing with a genetic
trait or a fungicide that's why I'm
quite confident whether we know from
fronting we recommend with fungicides
don't rely on just on the fungicide use
other mechanisms for Disease Control or
the tactics you know so I'm saying that
as as an academician knowing that in
reality it's you know growers have a lot
of things to be concerned about they may
not always do what they should but our
you know our job first is to understand
the biology and I think the biology is
pretty sound that we you know we want to
we at least know that we should be
recommending alternatives and other
tactics for disease control and
implement it as best we can but nobody
back to your specific question I'm not
seeing studies that integrate the two I
think think we have a lot of experience
research-based experience with
everything else you know the host plant
resistance through conventional means
and all other cultural and chemical
methods to know that that that an
integrative approach is is ultimately
better for lots of reasons but no one's
specifically done that yet with CRISPR
technologies
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu